This is a book saying
there are black people
who need help, and the people
who are calling themselves
black people saviors now
don't understand this,
but they're hurting black people,
because what they're caught up in
is more about virtue
signaling to one another
than helping people
who actually need help.
In his bestselling new book, "Woke Racism,
How a New Religion has
Betrayed Black America,"
New York Times columnist and
Columbia University linguist,
John McWhorter argues that
the ideas of Robin Diangelo,
Ibram X. Kendi, and the 1619 Project
undermine blacks by
sharpening racial divides
and distracting from actual
obstacles to real progress.
Reason spoke with the
56-year-old McWhorter
about what whites get out of cooperating
with an ideological agenda
that cast them as devils,
what blacks gained by
performing victim-hood,
and what needs to change,
so that all Americans can get on
with creating a more perfect union.